the amount of times i've had people come
up to me you don't know friends
you want some no photo why do you want a
photo i thought no friends
how are you doing i'm done nice to meet
you
[Music]
all right your first question how did
you gain your viral film
i was at football match uh wolfstone
against the
team in brighton i don't want to mention
their names i don't like them that much
two people followed me about for about
20 minutes half hour as you said i speak
a bit funny i don't look normal so i
started taking mitti out of my accent
and
the way i was i must admit i was a bit
intoxicated
but everybody's got a breaking point so
you've been pushed you've been pushed to
it yeah
the rest is basically history so i
defended myself and then it went viral
yeah i've i've i've seen it i've seen it
it's a good video so
what about you um i was on a bbc
documentary
when i was 16. in the documentary i was
i was a bodybuilder and it followed me
around
my diet was six meals of fish and rice
cakes all right
it takes me a fish and every other meal
was a rice cake yeah but instead of just
me just saying that
they've caught that little thing on the
documentary and makes me look
stupid like pretty stupid so when the
documentary came out
it social media wasn't a big thing so i
sort of got away with it
and then uh scott mills kept playing it
like about
three years later so people were
messaging me and
and stuff like that and i'm not as
stupid as the video makes out i'm still
pretty stupid but i'm not as stupid as
that
uh when it first came out the sunday
after my friend phoned me up
he said do you know you're on youtube
and i
first of all i thought i might get away
with a thousand
views and it kept going up
up up and then it stopped at about ten
thousand
and i thought yeah i've got ray with
this that is it
and then suddenly everything on facebook
names
videos it's all about me next when i
looked on youtube it had about five
million views
it was there i didn't even go around my
local paper shop
one minute you're walking down the
street you're a normal everyday person
next thing you're catapulted all over
the place
do you understand the way it went viral
yes and no it says i'm small
and the way i speak
i think between they realized i was
being bullied by these three people
and someone was videoing it to bury me
even more i think the british public
don't like all that situation so i think
they embraced it me
getting up for myself i think i'd given
people
the underdog can actually prevail
about you i understand why because it is
actually hilarious
like i do look it's totally stupid it's
quite funny but
it does it does get to you sometimes
yeah that moment
how did the public react when they see
you on the street
well i'm lucky enough that i don't look
anything like
i did when i was 16 which i don't think
anyone really does today so
it's kind of when people not find out
it's me which normally is on like
facebook or something like danny andrews
they'll be like
are you the fish and rice cake guy and
i'm like oh no cause then they've got a
preconceived idea of what you are
before they've even met you so they
think that i'm just a a stupid 16 year
old when i'm
like a 30 year old man like i'll get
people that coming to my barber shop
that no
no fine well that i'm the fish and rice
cake guy i could feel him setting it up
to say
and they're going so do you train and
because i don't go to the gym i'm like
no and then they're like um so you don't
got the gym anymore
and it's the first time they've been in
for a hug and i just know that they're
dying to just say a fish in a rice cake
and then
when they sometimes give you he's like
about it it
it's like it's the first time that like
it's like oh yo it's been like
how many years it's been 14 years and
they're going to me fishing
hey fish on a rice fishing i'm like i've
had 14 years of this like
it's they're acting like it's the first
time that someone's ever said it to me
so
it's like when i'm just like rolling my
eyes it's hard isn't it to be
do you know what some days when you
probably you're not when you're tired
and you can't be
i bet it's annoying when people start
going you've got no offense do you know
what stuff
is there ever times when you get annoyed
at it at the end of the day
people don't know your mood so you've
just got to be
a normal everyday person try and make
them people happy yeah yeah
and just do you never get it in a
negative way like do people not like
people not say is it always positive
when they say you still didn't
negatively
how did you react to that you just just
ignore them smile
smile they won the reaction of you like
today
they'll turn around put it on social
media i met the real stone rider
he was all right beep for himself
he smiled at him yes sir no sir
that's why the trolls are just when they
troll me i give my little happy face
that winds them up even more they want
you to react
so then they got a story at nothing
so just smile what's the worst thing
that's
happened to you because of your fame
being knocked out of him uh
yeah when i got knocked out this was
about
six seven months after the video first
came out and after the song came out
you had a song yeah i didn't sonic my
number five in the charts at christmas
everything went for charity every penny
went for charity it's a bad song but
we don't know 99 of the people are
brilliant they come up ask for
photographs
and not not point one percent you've got
to be aware of because as i said i've
been assaulted
i've run for the bus this sparta knocked
out
it's not nice to wake up in an ambulance
and find out you've got a beard on the
brain
which very simple i was very surprised
that i didn't think i had a brain
they managed to find something there
anyway so and that is the downside of it
yeah i've not had any uh physical
violence but like
but when i go out on nights out and
stuff if someone catches wind of it
jesus christ like they'll be like hey
fishing or ice cake
fish boy talking to a girl online and
then finding out that
i'm fishing a rice cake and then just
never speaking to me again
you don't repent of fish i'm not on
plenty of fish no i've not tried that
one
take your fish and wife's tapes oh no
he's shredding me
sorry about it
oh god it's just because of that
horrible video
i tell you what the amount of times i've
had people come up to me you don't know
french
you want shop no photo why do you want a
photo i don't know french
if you could choose not to have it
out there or choose to have it would you
would you have it out there
i haven't really done oh it's hard to
explain
i actually never wanted to be famous
but it happened and you can't turn the
top back
no but i wouldn't have it what you've
got to do is replace it
when it all first came out uh the
president of russia and football
dragged me into the office so we thought
we're gonna do this
when you embrace it we're gonna earn as
much money as we possibly can for
charity
i i'm actually a patron for charity
called life for a kid foundation
and this charity is absolutely amazing
i had made over half a million pounds of
charity
and i don't think i'd have been a patron
of this charity
if it wasn't if it wasn't finished so
you've had all this like you've spun it
all positive where i
shy away like i get offered things doing
like tv things and
inbox all the time but i i'm nervous
that something else and they might get
something else on me and
like i'll be portrayed in a different
kind of light to what i'm like so i'm
always nervous about that
you would never yeah that's part and
parcel
yeah only because i felt like not that i
was stitched up but like
because i didn't they've seen that video
but i couldn't say my
part on the video like sammy's memory
yeah yeah so
like i was the same i've only seen your
video but now you've got the platform
so if you want to embrace it just get in
you'll tell you it yeah yeah
and then you realize how fulfilling
being famous can't be
yeah i won't class myself as famous but
people are coming up to you and after
you for focus
yeah yeah maybe yeah yeah
just let people know that you're a nice
person and that was 14 years later
yeah yeah to be fair like the
preconceived
idea i had a view was totally different
to what i've like i'm hearing about your
charity and stuff like that like
i just thought you were like a drunken
football hooligan fan thing so i just
thought you were a man
you're
how did you feel like about like the
people mocking you like the negative
comments and stuff
it did upset me some there's some
horrible people out there
really horrible people first of all
first of all i won't use to it
if you've got nothing fair to do to sit
on a keyboard
and insult people you're not worth
writing about the first place are you
right
so interesting well some of them are
quite funny like they say
like oh like there'll be some quest
there'll be some comments saying like i
thought
fish was brain food obviously not um
there was other ones saying that
my shirt's like an old caravan curtain
well people like proper passionate about
about about how they feel about me when
they've watched a
10 second clip of me when i was 16 years
old and that
that kind of gets to me but i just try
not to read them because i just think oh
that's not
me there's no point yeah yeah it's not
worth it
no what's the point of upsetting
yourself yeah yeah that's what i do now
and i i understand that there will be
there's always going to be
negative yeah i'd like to save some
positives but that generally
isn't on my videos
what's the funniest thing that's ever
happened to you because of your
viral fear tyson fury's pressed himself
wedding
he put something on instagram i'm on the
train not rush down right up for this
boxing
match so anyway i've got a phantom
do i fancy interrupting tyson fury's
press conference and doing the rain
of course petrified but you don't do it
so i turned up at manchester and just
walked in
the middle of state sports tv and
interrupted
question french i i love tyson fury
enough
josie my toe yeah don't show me okay can
you see it yeah oh yeah that's very good
when i was in madison few years ago two
people they've got a tattoo on my
face on their bum that is class i am
serious
that's gonna be my next one i'm a legend
are you proud of what you've achieved
looking back then i was a 16 year old
just working in a gym
um in like a like a council flat to
i've just bought a detached
three-bedroom home
on my own and i've got a business i've
got three people working for me
from seeing what i've what i've come
from and what i did in bodybuilding as
well because
i don't train now but i used to like
take it like quite seriously as a junior
bodybuilder i like won everything apart
from the universe come involved in
and that's just a different chapter in
my life now i'm on to my next chapter
from from then to now i am i'm proud
what's the best thing that has happened
to you because of your fame
meeting you yeah no that's going to be
that that's going to be my answer
i've done you already no that's my
answer meeting you
my friends are going to love the fact i
met you today
what advice would you do to someone who
has just done
very famous um don't read the comments
you always end up the negative people as
you said don't worry about the comments
embrace the positives and if you feel
like it
try and do as much as you possibly can
for charity well it's good meeting you
nice to meet you
it's been a pleasure anyway after do she
stands your point yeah
seriously so what happened before
you were diagnosed um with me it was a
lot of losing
time a lot of um not remembering where
i'd been what happened
and lots of like who am i what's going
on where
am i i've always had that um like
lack of memory and not knowing what's
happening